- This is like all of my
worst fears manifested.
(electronic music)
- Today, I'm cutting my bestfriend's hair.
(laughing)
- I am very excited, actually.
I always love a new
haircut and I trust her.
- Well, I'm thinking like a Rachel Bilson
from circa OC era, you know.
So, just like nice long layers,
a little bit off the length.
- I want to give her bangs.
I think she has the face for bangs.
- Oh, thanks.
- Yeah, she has nice cheekbones.
- I think that I can do this.
I'm feeling really confident.
- I hope you can do this.
- I'm feeling really good.
(suspenseful music)
- Please don't cut my eyelashes.
- [Carmeyn] I'm not going to.
- [Lindsay] Just take
off these little ends.
- Okay.
- [Liz] Oh, maybe less.
(laughing)
- What are you doing?
- Just giving you dimension?
- Oh my God.
(laughing)
- Okay, we're good.
- [Lindsay] No, no, no. No shakes.
- Why are you, why are
you talking like that?
You're talking like an evil genius
and it's making me semi-uncomfortable.
(laughing)
- What was that for?
- Is this how you usually part your hair?
- You know, I do both. I do
middle. I do some side parts.
- I don't think that it will matter.
I just felt like that might be comforting.
(laughing)
- [Carmeyn] We've been friends
for so long, Elizabeth.
(laughing)
- Let's keep it that way.
- You have very good bedside hair manner.
You sound confident and
because you sound confident
I feel a little better.
- Good.
- Oh my God.
(laughing)
- [Carmeyn] I know, I know.
- It sounds like a lot.
- [Lindsay] This looks good.
- Does it?
- [Lindsay] Oh, yeah.
- So would you go out to
lunch with me like this?
- Yeah, I would go to
lunch with you in any way.
- What are you hoping to see
when you look in the mirror?
- I'm hoping to not cry.
(suspenseful music)
- What? This isn't bad.
- Really?
- Yeah, you're good.
- You think so?
- [Alana] Okay.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, you did good.
- Okay, good. I'm really glad. Oh my God.
- You know, I may not even
have to go to the salon.
Look at you.
- I know.
- We did it.
- Yeah, it's like a rollercoaster.
It was fun and scary at the same time.
- Hey, I may be calling
you up in 3 months like,
"Hey girl. Hey girl.
Hook me up with a trim."
- I love her.
- I love her and let's go
out. Let's go flaunt this.
- I know, we're going to rock
this out to lunch right now.
(electronic music)